France and England later Britain have
not had the best relationship in the 500
years before the end of Napoleon the two
have been at war for a hundred and sixty
four of them and the rest of them they
spent not exactly being keen on one
another yet throughout the last seven
hundred years there have been numerous
attempts to unify the two entities but
how close did they come to fruition did
Britain and France almost become one
country now the first time that there
was any real chance of unification was
at the height of the Hundred Years War
when England for the help of Burgundy
had won numerous victories their success
peaked in 1422 when the child King Henry
the sixth was crowned King Henry ii of
france now henry didn't control all of
france and with the help of a certain
Joan of Arc France won the Hundred Years
War and the English were pushed out King
George the 3rd was the last British mana
to formally claim the French throne
since he renounced his claim in 1801
when Great Britain was merged with
Island so it was in 1940 that the most
famous attempt to unify the two came
about this happened after the Allied
front line collapsed and France was on
the brink of being conquered by Germany
naturally everyone was panicking and so
the British made a proposal both nations
and their empire should unify into a
single entity the franco-british Union
the new constitution was going to be
drafted which would unite some of the
organs of government defense and foreign
policy would be conducted from London
the nation's new capital whereas the new
nation's finances would be administered
from French territory what was left of
it that is the British and French
Parliament's would as a stopgap have to
both pass the same legislation for it to
come into effect until they were merged
the positions of each of the head of
state would be extended to the other
meaning France would have a king again
and Britain would have a president
beyond this there weren't many concrete
plans because everyone was panicking
about the war in France surrendering
also as a side note it was expected that
the other states that have fallen to
Germany would also join this Union too
so it wouldn't be France and Britain for
long in the end these proposals never
went anywhere because whilst prominent
politicians on both sides favoured the
Union many Frenchmen didn't want to sign
their country's existence away many of
them felt that they were being forced to
choose between military submission to
Germany or political and economic
submission to Britain and they chose the
former the next and final time many
politicians attempted to merge the two
nations was in 1956 after the Suez
Crisis which saw Britain France and
Israel invade Egypt to prevent it from
seizing the Suez Canal was an absolute
failure the two powers became desperate
it was an international embarrassment
and it looked clear to both that they
were now firmly junior partners to the
USA if they were to protect their
crumbling empires something would need
to be done as such guy Malay the French
Prime Minister proposed the
franco-british union to the British
Prime Minister Harold Macmillan the plan
was that both would unite into a single
nation with Queen Elizabeth the second
taking the title queen of France this
government would be devolved and both
would maintain separate budgets but
their armed forces and empires would be
merged and it was hoped that the two
combined would act as a third pillar in
the Cold War
this time discussions didn't go very far
McMillan said no and the reason was that
there was literally a 0% chance that the
British or French publics would have
gone along with this McMillan was
personally against the Union and
preferred for a new European economic
Union to counterbalance the USSR in the
USA which did happen and to which
Britain wasn't invited after this both
nations would remain separate in the
franco-british Union would go down as a
curious idea brought up when both
nations faced a crisis I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with the special thanks to my
patrons James Bissonnette John lucid a
man of culture Danny Maloney little
holiday John biscuits Rob Waterhouse mo
James Castaneda Aaron the White Jordan
Longley Gustav Swan marcus asana rashid
ali spinning three plates filled oink
oink David Silverman
Maggie packs Kowski Spencer Lightfoot
Lexi Schwinn Kelly moneymaker
Anthony Beckett Robert Wetzel Skye
Chappell Marvin Castle Winston Hayward
and Izzy also let's be reasonable it
would have fallen apart like five
minutes after the war was over